ladies and gentlemen we got em one of
the biggest
stories for sure of the last three
months
if not the last three years the new york
times
has obtained donald trump's tax return
data
extending over more than two decades
the contents of the tax information
is absolutely stunning is it devastating
to trump
i don't know i don't know that his
followers care about anything at this
point
we will talk about that but this is much
of but not all
much of what many have been waiting for
for years donald trump's tax returns
which he said in 2015
once he's no longer under audit he would
release whatever happened to that
we know that he was just lying well they
are now out some of the revelations
include
donald trump paid a total of 750
in federal income taxes the year that he
won the presidency
750 dollars total
in his first year in the white house his
total
federal tax payments were
fifty 750 he paid no
federal income taxes at all
in ten of the previous 15 years none
how much did you pay how much did i pay
if i showed you the amount of federal
tax
i paid and the amount trump paid you
would assume
i made way more money than donald trump
in these years
uh this entire decade-long
audit battle with the internal revenue
service
has been exposed as being over the
legitimacy
of a nearly 73 million dollar
tax refund that donald trump claimed
understand that
donald trump filed taxes claiming he was
entitled
to 72.9 million dollars of a tax refund
he received that tax refund and that
is now in being investigated donald
trump may have
stolen 73 million dollars from you
for me from whoever else actually paid
taxes and if indeed
that was an inappropriate refund that he
claimed he may be on the hook for 100
million dollars once you account for the
fees and fines
um on top of all of this the documents
do confirm that donald trump has been
overstating
his business strength in 2018 as an
example
donald trump disclosed in a financial
disclosure which is not a legal document
that he made 435 million dollars
the tax records say he lost 47 million
dollars now
of course if you want to seem rich but
save on taxes
you would disclose a lot of money
and you would argue for tax purposes you
lost money this is a gap of more than
500 million dollars
and it is connected to all of these
other very clear instances
of donald trump claiming that people
need to pay they pay their fair share
donald trump's tweets about half of
americans pay no federal tax
because they don't produce anything
trump's the one barely paying federal
taxes
every single thing we thought trump
might be hiding
he's hiding we said you know trump might
be hiding that he's paying very little
in taxes despite being a super rich dude
that is exactly right we said you know
trump might be hiding that
his businesses aren't really doing so
well he's not as wealthy as he wants
people to think
and that is exactly right we said he
might
owe people a ton of money making him a
good target
and that is exactly right the documents
that the new york times has obtained
show that donald trump has 300 million
dollars in loans
which he is personally responsible for
they come due
in the next few years if trump is
re-elected we will have a president
who uh owes 300 million dollars and has
to start paying it back during his
second term and in total
421 million dollars in debt is donald
trump
to whom does he owe that money that's a
real question that's always by the way
josh campbell former
fbi agent said when you vet people
for federal government jobs if they have
a lot of debt
that is a red flag because it makes them
potentially
um vulnerable to being pressured because
of those debts that they have
look at what donald trump owes and then
as always with donald trump there's a
tweet for everything
donald trump tweeting in 2012 that quote
barack obama
who wants to raise all our taxes only
pays
20.5 percent on a seven hundred and
ninety thousand dollar salary
do as i say not as i do pays twenty
percent
trump paid zero dollars
in ten of the last fifteen years now the
important question
in the end because we're 40 days from an
election we are
five weeks from an election the question
in the end is does this make a
difference will this
influence voters i don't know that it
will this
obviously runs completely counter to
what donald trump ran on donald trump
ran on him for the middle class
donald trump ran on i'm from personal
responsibility we have too many people
who pay no taxes blah blah blah blah
blah
remember that during the 2016 election
when the narrative was
it takes someone to know how to play the
game in order to fix it for everybody
that's what trump ran
on okay yeah listen maybe i know how to
play the game so i'm going to fix it
didn't quite pan out did it
who would have thought that a giant
beneficiary of the system might want to
maintain it
obviously as we've been saying and yet
so many people are worse off
economically
now than they were when donald trump
took office
and trump's the one paying 750 in
federal taxes
the people who will be appalled by this
though
they're already not voting for donald
trump i was already getting tweets
yesterday from people saying dude
this is why trump's so smart he hasn't
paid taxes in years legally or
hey listen trump's business has lost
money some years
so those years he shouldn't be paying
taxes and what's hilariously
hypocritical about these
overlapping rebuttals is that you've got
the same people who are saying hey
listen if trump's
business has lost money he shouldn't be
paying taxes those are the same people
who say trump's a business genius well
hold on a second which one is it
which one is it so in the end i don't
know if this is going to move the needle
it only needs to move the needle a
little bit if we can get if this story
gets a few people to vote who weren't
going to
it could be so close in some key states
that it might actually make a difference
in the end
now on the back end of this story there
is an even bigger story there's a
systemic story here
which is much bigger than trump and i
think that for the next 40 days the
story is
trump and his taxes in 41 days
assuming joe biden wins the story here
is we have a tax system set up
to help the really wealthy avoid paying
taxes
in mostly legal ways although again
donald trump may have taken a 73 million
dollar refund that he didn't actually
deserve
so this is about donald trump but it's
also about systemic abuse
it's about how warren buffett has
famously pointed out
that there are years where his effective
tax rate was lower than his secretaries
if i recall correctly i'm going from
memory
warren buffett a turbo billionaire
warren buffett
once said that there was a year where
his effective tax rate was like 17
and his secretaries was 21
that's really the big story here beyond
donald trump
we're going to have plenty of time to
deal with that story but for the next 40
days
does this hurt trump let me know what
you think one of our sponsors is
privacy.com they're giving you five
dollars when you sign up for their
completely
free service at privacy.com pacman i've
been using privacy for a little over a
year now you've heard me talk about it
before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes
to set up anytime you buy something
online or on the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app
and the browser plugin let you give each
company
a randomized virtual credit card number
that you create
out of thin air it'll even autofill the
card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information
so this allows you to keep your banking
information secure but also to take
control of your finances you can create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set
spending limits you can freeze them you
can delete them anytime you want so when
you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over if i use a virtual credit card
number
you're keeping your identity private by
not telling companies who you
are you're keeping your bank or credit
card info protected against data
breaches
and identity theft and it's free there's
no catch whatsoever but
if you want privacy also offers a ten
dollar a month plan
that gives you one percent cash back and
lets you create 36
credit cards a month and a 25 a month
plan tailored more for small businesses
where you can create
60 card numbers a month and much more
but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like i
said
you'll get five dollars to spend when
you sign up
at privacy.com slash pacman